oh
stop
don't stop happy Tuesday everybody it is
Tuesday right thank you so why is
Twitter causing such emotional Strife in
the government and in the media well
they were the junkies and their drug
dealer just got killed
Elon Musk now runs the corner with new
rules and new prices and the junkies are
screaming this just isn't fair but it is
it's fairer than cat's skin after giving
two pints of blood in February
and whoever wrote that is kind of
freaking me out now
but when you're used to preferential
treatment you always complain when the
fields are finally level that's what
you're seeing with Twitter changing the
media is losing their lie insurance
Twitter was to the media what cow
farmers are to McDonald's what college
football is to the NFL what KFC is to
Joy behar's ass
it was the assembly line of approved
opinions to bolster their ideologies
listen to this White House reporter
begging the White House to say that
they'll get involved
this is a critical moment really in
terms of ensuring that Twitter does not
become a vector for misinformation I
mean are you concerned who is it at the
White House that is really keeping track
of this and social media companies have
a responsibility to prevent their
platforms from being used by any user to
incite violence especially violence
directed at individual communities as we
have been seeing and the president has
been very clear on calling that out
he'll continue to do that and we're
going to continue to monitor the
situation
monitoring the situation can you blame
them for freaking out it's like pulling
a rattle out of a teething baby's mouth
and saying no more you whiny little brat
remember in the old days journalists had
beats they covered local government
crime Sports back then no one covered
soccer
[Laughter]
you had to call people and get quotes
and write a story based on your notes in
a little Notepad
but that changed with Twitter tweets
replaced beats and now they think those
tweets are gone forever and it's scary
because journalists relied on Twitter to
tell them what to think and what the
news was which is like getting your
drinking water from your neighbor's
septic tank
but if it trended on Twitter they jumped
on it quicker than me on a story about a
trans teacher with giant boobs
I'm not gonna let it go I think I think
the audience is with me
thank you yes
[Applause]
but what trended is what only turned on
in activists usually a 20 year old with
hygiene issues and undefined sexual
problems that require him to Scotch
Guard his mouse pad
foreign
people guide them Twitter provided the
opinions which is why you hear the same
ones over and over again in the media
now one original thought and that's bad
for political discourse but great for
forcing people to say men can have
babies
it's amazing to watch the people feed
off others like a soccer team whose
plane crashed on a mountain
oh
it's the best thing that ever happened
to soccer I joke I joke
meanwhile Twitter's previous bosses axed
anything that would interfere with a
biased narrative you know like a story
about a certain crackhead in his laptop
now you see why these hacks are so
terrified they might have to actually
work for a living musk took their cheat
sheet away and they're already in full
meltdown mode
it's amazing to watch someone like Elon
Musk who is such a um he's such a child
you know he's so immature he needs
attention all the time and these guys
with these money and these detention and
these daddy issues his libertarian
nonsense is is destructive to American
National Security and he has got to
reinstitute the same restrictions that
were on Twitter before he bought it and
that sort of speaks to how he's been
governing over at Twitter not much
transparency into what's going on just
really him uh ruling by tweets there's
something very dangerous about him he
reminds me of a bond villain as I said
when the richest guy in the world buys a
social media platform it's just not a
good equation I think he's a dangerous
fellow but dangerous fella says the
stupid guy at MSNBC
kind of have to applaud don't have to
plot save that for later when I take off
my shirt
so it's weird how did a media come to
find a person who's expanding free
speech to be so dangerous well this is
what happens when one defines
disagreeableness as hate speech and hate
speech then as a crime because then Free
Speech becomes a crime for allowing
disagreeable speech
so they don't want what Elon wants which
is a Town Square unless they could run
it like Tiananmen they wanted a private
club with a Velvet Rope that kept scrubs
like you out it's why a tiny percentage
of Twitter users were responsible for
nearly all the tweets and those are the
people you see in panic mode you know a
rocket scientist named Alyssa Milano a
nuclear physicist named Rob Reiner
a world-renowned heart surgeon named
Deborah Messing
but it's no surprise they're mad now
we'll be able to see when their pants
are on fire
and we're already seeing how musk is
planning to expose their prior failures
too on Monday he tweeted the Twitter
files on Free Speech suppression soon to
be published on Twitter itself the
public deserves to know what really
happened so he's clearly alluding to
Twitter censoring the New York Post
Hunter Biden laptop story before the
2020 election a story that the rest of
the media is finally admitting was true
all along when it's safe to
although it's just in time for that new
Hunter Biden Christmas special
that I've been hearing about I can't
wait
this holiday season don't punish
yourself with another boring rerun blow
the roof off the Jump with an
unforgettable special for the ages it's
a hunter Biden Christmas you'll see
Hunter being naughty playing in the snow
and baking cookies with his meth dealer
Enrique plus you'll see a moving
performance of Oh Holy Night by hunters
and what holiday special would be
complete without a hair sniffing visit
from the big guy himself it's a hunter
Biden Christmas next Thursday at 8 only
on Fox
[Music]
yeah
that's what I call a truly White
Christmas
[Applause]
as a lawyer and cheerleader she was
known for her motions outnumbered
co-host Emily cabano
the opinions he write keeps liberals up
at night Fox News contributor in
Washington Times opinion editor Charlie
heard
and she'll steal your heart while going
through your wallet Fox News contributor
Kat Tim
and finally Santa sits on his lap for
Christmas my massive sidekick in the NWA
World hello heavyweight champion Tyrus
is that you no uh I feel like that was
you no no no no no
I didn't write any of that no I'm
kidding Emily great to see you again
great to be here I know it really is it
must be great for you to be on this show
what do you make about the the this kind
of I don't know this uh I hate to use
the word melting down but it's more like
you know this kind of irrational concern
that's coming from the media and the
government no I think it would be
amusing it would be laughable if it
didn't actually have real world
consequences on so many people you know
this is the same group of people so we
have the White House Press Secretary
saying that they are monitoring the
platform for hate that's the most
important thing on the president's
agenda meanwhile the Ayatollah has been
texting or tweeting freely on it the
whole time these are the same lawmakers
number one among them Kamala Harris who
are in bed with the social media
platforms it's the reason why none of
them are liable for anything that
happens on it so when people have
enjoyed live stream of rapes and people
you know gather garnering support for
really terrible horrible violent crimes
no one at the top is ever held
accountable because of these people in
charge in this Administration right it's
just the users but they flip that point
of view when all of a sudden Elon Musk
is the reason that the world is falling
apart
um and this is the same president who I
guess again this is his priority but he
decides to take Air Marshals off planes
put them at the southern border right
our dollars going up there are so many
things in this world that are consuming
Americans that are true stressors and
yet this is what is consuming our
Administration this is what our tax
dollars are funding is their hair
catching on fire yeah this I wouldn't
knock the ayatollah's tweets they are
pretty good um did you see his top 10
list of Christmas movies
is Hunter Biden's Christmas on them
Scrooge with number one which I was
totally surprised you didn't have a
Christmas story on there I totally get
with the program Charlie pleasure seeing
you as well uh what do you make of the
fact that they're so scared I really do
believe this has to do with hate speech
now now being broadened to include
anything disagreeable oh I think you're
exactly right
um and and what's so amazing about it is
to listen to people in the Press yeah
they're the ones that are the most upset
about it and it's you know you and if
you step back and you take a something
like Twitter which is kind of the most
amazing Democrat democratizing tool in
the world for free speech and only these
people could take it and twist it around
and turn it into a weapon in order to
silence the people that not only silence
their enemies but what you're pointing
out which I think is is exactly what
they're doing they're actually making uh
their opponents and what their opponents
support like illegal right and illicit
and and verboten and um that's German
right uh yeah I think so so I want to
check but but it really is amazing to
you know we hear these people they they
talk so much about threats to democracy
and they ran the whole last election
about threats to democracy and the
greatest the single greatest threat to
the democracy is these people colluding
between the collusion between the media
and people like Joe Biden and Democrats
uh in order to silence the electorate
because without an informed electorate
you don't have a republic yeah it's
funny because these are the people
talking about misinformation and
disinformation that's a little Rich cat
don't you think yep yep try to think of
like an analogy like Twitter being taken
over Elon Musk that was something that
would upset the Republicans would be
like like the NRA choosing a new
president and it's I don't know Alyssa
Milano or something like that or just
Twitter before Elon Musk yes that's
right yeah yeah because all of the
things that conservatives were
complaining about and people were saying
oh that's crazy you're not being Shadow
banned or oh there's no politically
motivated algorithms keep in mind the
only thing that people on the left are
upset about is that conservatives were
right the whole time yes yeah but we're
expected to just not care yeah and
they're they're really trying to um
they're trying and failing to sort of
make it seem like Elon is hypocritical
I've seen a lot of people okay well you
know if he's that libertarian police and
Free Speech well you know you can't do
anything about Apple wants to do it's
like yeah he said he didn't like it he
didn't say that there should be a law to
stop Apple from doing this all that the
libertarian or the Free Speech point of
view says is you can just say what you
want you can do what you want and I'm
not going to interfere with that I don't
think the government should interfere
with that and just because it's not a
First Amendment violation doesn't mean
that it doesn't go against the cultural
value of free speech which also has
value whether first amendment applies to
it or not
look at that the scholarship
but what what I don't know what are you
kidding me I'm looking at you I have to
look at you you're the host yeah that's
true
all right you know what I know it's hard
okay yeah I just look above
um
listen this is any any time you've seen
in court where a victim uh of a horrible
crime the other attorney's job is to
make them look like something's wrong
with them you know like a rape victim
they bring up her her sexual past to try
to like diminish her they have they have
used Twitter as their front line defense
and filter they've used it to go after
enemies they've used it to protect
themselves they use it to protect their
guy the hunter Biden story would have
certainly cost him the election so they
squashed it and they squashed story of
the story and then anybody they wanted
to choose to go after to end them it
wasn't through courts it wasn't through
the police it was through Twitter they
can't canceled they became woke
Elon by opening up is now showing the
crimes they committed the things that
they did wrong so what do you do
you own it no you have to make Elon a
criminal yeah so they now use words that
mean nothing it's he's attacking Free
Speech how is he doing that he didn't
say this is the new right tweet and
replace the bird with an elephant you
know what I'm saying he just said we can
all talk yeah
because which leads which means things
are going to come out right and he's
he's messing with them I'm going to put
the information because there's going to
be conversations just like there was
those text messages about President
Trump going we cannot let this happen
right we have the FBI agents we're
texting back and forth and how they were
going to go to get rid of them those
things were happening in Twitter and
they didn't unlike the FBI who are the
the ones it had to be secretive they
were just talking about it they were
doing it so they have to create him they
have to make him a criminal they have to
spin it and they're going to pull in all
their allies that's why the White House
is watching and suddenly Apple all of a
sudden cares about free speech and
platforms right meanwhile in China where
their phones are made it's horrible over
there they got nothing to say yeah
because they have to make Elon a
criminal yeah yeah there you go all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else